Adam rip on gushes over Britney Spears I
think she's so incredible his love life
you have a boyfriend I do and Dancing
with the Stars they would be pretty
awesome
[Music]
the 28 year old Olympic figure skater
hit up the GLAAD Media Awards Thursday
night in LA where he rubbed elbows with
pop royalty Britney Spears who received
glides Vanguard Award and looked
incredible in a sparkly Giannina Azure
mini dress one of the things I really
like about her is how open her Instagram
account is for somebody who's as popular
as Britney to just show that you can
just be yourself
you can post funny things and she's so
authentically herself that I think that
she is such a positive role model
continuing his winning streak up next
Adam is set to compete on Dancing with
the Stars athletes he learned he'd be
competing earlier this month but still
he's staying coy if I were on Dancing
with the Stars it would be pretty
awesome I don't know how to dance so it
would for sure be a challenge and
despite his busy schedule Adams still
finds time for romance he recently
started dating his boyfriend Jessi Pekka
we actually met on tinder I actually was
at a competition in Finland and he's
from Finland and we met while we were in
Finland so isn't that crazy what are the
chances
[Music]
[Applause]